millions of americans who hit the road
for easter or passover found it costs a
little less to drive that's good news
aaa reports the average price of gas
nationwide has fallen about 24 cents in
the last five weeks to four dollars and
nine cents a gallon president biden has
taken steps to bring that number down
because it's still considered high
wishes shows us the latest effort to
control gas prices and why some of the
president's allies still don't like it
as the russian invasion causes
instability in the global energy market
president biden wants to ramp up
domestic oil production he is already
tapping the nation's strategic petroleum
reserve to help slash gas prices and now
the administration plans to resume
selling leases for new oil and gas
drilling on 144 000 acres of public
lands in nine states even though mr
biden made this promise on the campaign
trail no more drilling on federal lands
period period period period
the department of interior called the
decision to open up more federal land
for drilling a balanced approach to
energy development but climate groups
are furious one group says while the
biden administration talks a good talk
on climate action the reality is they
are in bed with the oil and gas industry
of course another big priority is
getting back to normal so here on the
south lawn this morning the white house
is getting ready to welcome about 30 000
visitors for the annual easter egg roll
which came to a halt in 2020 because of
the pandemic but very lucky children are
already waiting outside and inside there
are 50 000 of these hard-boiled eggs for
the easter egg roll races with wooden
spoons some decorating some aegons but
gail
with this bump i have i'm about to roll
myself down the mountain
i know it's a little bigger but it'll
work yeah
uh your bump looks great i was thinking
weeja you got to breathe i remember
those days but baby thank you baby
squeezes our organs but it's worth
everything looks great
fantastic you're doing a great job i
hear ed o'keefe is in that line with his
two little kids i hope we get video of
that thank you weeja